so the quizzes are not meant to be
difficult they're mostly meant to be to
to
provide some incentives for you to a uh
keep up with the class
b um to do the readings see to come to
class
uh are they actually a commitment device
or not
yes
uh in general either quizzes uh
commitment device or not
by the definition that we had why is
that
because
[Music]
right but i guess um one condition that
we have in the commitment devices and
that's more like a question of
definition it's like
it's chosen by the agent to actually
engage in this and i guess you don't
have the choice so in some sense if i
offer to you to choose quizzes versus
not
and you could particularly only do worse
by doing the quizzes that could offer
you the choice either you had always
five in the quizzes
or you can opt in to saying you do the
quizzes
then you know you're choosing the
quizzes would very much be in a
commitment device but if i sort of just
impose it on you
then strictly speaking it is it is not
even though it sort of functions in the
exact same way
as if you had uh chosen it um okay
mostly we are discussing empirical
questions um uh related to hyperbolic
requisite hyperbolic discounting
i want to have a short intermezzo very
briefly about sort of
telling you about how to solve problems
with quite the hyperbolic discounting in
part because that's relevant to the
problem set
i already talked with you briefly about
sort of how do you deal with like fully
naive agents
how do you deal with fully sophisticated
agents in some sense it's fairly simple
in these two cases
in part because these are special
extreme cases
now the third case
the third case is what do you do when
you have a partially naive
decision maker and that's a little
trickier and we tend to not have
um that many problems related to
partially
decision makers of course in part it's
like a little tricky to do
so essentially what you do is you kind
of do the same as you do for the fully
sophisticated decision maker you
do start by doing backwards induction
you essentially solve for what does the
person
think they're gonna do in the future
right for that
um i'm speechless uh
for that um uh
for for that what you do is um you you
use people's beta hat um and
the hat is essentially what the person
believes they will do in the future
and then essentially solve using
backward seduction what the person
thinks they will do
this is the exact same thing as you do
for a fully sophisticated person except
for that you're using now people's beta
hat as opposed to people's
actual beta the difference is of course
it's always the beta hat it just happens
to be for the
sophisticated person that the beta hat
actually is the beta
right so then you do essentially you
start at the end you do backwards
induction you go back in time work
yourself since it's period two
so then the person using their beta hat
knows what they're gonna do in the
future
thinks they knows what they're gonna
view in the future starting in the next
period
then you're gonna start solving for the
first period like what is the person
actually gonna do
for that what you need is like the
person's actual beta because that's
essentially what determines people's
actual choices
um and then you go to the next period
and do exactly the same thing again you
do sort of backwards induction you
already have solved that from the
previous
uh uh step but then essentially in
period two then the person actually uses
again their actual beta for making their
decisions
right so the beta hats are guiding
people's beliefs about what they think
they will do in the future
but then you have to go back and
actually look at like what does the
person actually do
and that often uh uh differs in
particular when you get to like period
two three and four
uh uh in the future uh
uh as i speak
um the second thing i wanted to say is
and this is mostly relevant for problem
set too
um so far we have essentially looked at
continuous choices right it's like going
to a movie versus not or at some point
you have like one movie that you can go
to
which essentially sort of following the
donahue raven papers and examples
you have one problem set you need to at
some point it's essentially a discrete
choice do you do it or
do you not do it of course many choices
in life
are exactly like that like essentially
uh when do you do the problem sets and
so on and so forth
um but other choices in life are
continuous consumption savings or
continuous choices right it's about like
how much do you eat how much do you
consume
and so on and so forth and sort of the
canonical thing to do in economics or
consumption savings choices right you
have some amount of money you think
about like how much would you consume in
this period
how much should you save there's an
interest rate you're going to get more
money than in the future if you save
more and so on and so forth
um the same principles here apply as
well except for now it's
you're not sort of comparing discrete
choices but now you do essentially for
sort of conditions the same what like
would you do in any uh
optimization problem as you would do in
uh 1401 or any sort of uh
into a micro class where essentially you
you you um
optimize uh uh using first order
conditions etc
uh subject to some some budget
constraint um
in the recitation you get some
additional guidance how to do that and
particularly um the tas will walk you
through a previous problem from like a
few years ago
that essentially sort of doing exactly
that i just want to sort of flag this
you're not surprised
uh this is essentially sort of 1401 uh
basics that we discussed in the first
presentation there's also some handout
on like
some refreshers for that but that'll
come as well but the same principle
supply here that's exactly the same
thing as we do here in the
in the other choices that people make um
except for now we have essentially uh
continuous choices any questions on this
okay all right so then we're going to
talk about other applications um
starting with
credit card uh teaser arrays or credit
card
behavior this is an old paper by ausubel
and bino you can have many concerns
about it but in some sense it sort of
nicely illustrates
a very simple uh uh behaviors that are
very nicely fitting into sort of the
quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model so this is um evidence
from using uh
real-world credit card usage so
essentially there's a company who has a
bunch of
uh data on credit card usages and as you
might be aware credit card companies
send out all sorts of mailers about
getting people to sign up
for a credit card in particular once
you're sort of out of school and have a
gainfully employed you get all sorts of
like uh
mailings and so on asking you to sign up
for credit cards
um now now
um in this particular example the
company um mailed out
uh randomized credit card offers of the
following types
there was like a standard credit card
offer which was um
a 6.9 interest rate for six months
and 16 afterwards so there's already
sort of in some sense a teaser rate
built in
in the sense of like it's starting to be
looks like it's really cheap you might
sort of think oh i'm gonna just borrow
for like a few
um a month and then you know eventually
it gets more expensive the hope of the
company of course is that you keep sort
of borrowing from them
once it actually gets more expensive and
then there's sort of two randomized
conditions there's the um
what they call the teaser deal which is
um 4.9 percent followed by
uh 16 and then there's what they call a
post teaser deal which is 6.9 percent
followed by
four percent right notice that like if
you sort of borrow
like a given amount for like quite a
while um uh
and that these two conditions are pretty
much similar depending a little bit how
long you borrow if you sort of borrow
for something
like a year then it's all about similar
the same if you borrow for more than a
year then you know
option three is probably better than
option two for you for a given amount
that you borrow
right so but what the company then has
is response rate um
and people's 21 month
borrowing history for individuals who
take up the card now these are kind of
selected so you want to be a little bit
careful how to interpret that
but sort of the response rates surely
are uh uh
the right thing to look at because it'd
be randomized across people who got
which letter
what they find is that the um the
response is about 2.5 points
times larger the increase and take up in
the second group relative to the third
group
now given subsequent borrowing behavior
and that's kind of like endogenous you
want to be a little bit careful with
that
but essentially if you look at people's
behavior uh the latter is a much better
uh
uh a deal right so you'd much rather
have as i said you might rather have
like
um deal number three uh compared to deal
number two
in particular if you like borrow for
like say two years like a thousand
dollars you're going to pay much more
interest
in deal number two compared to number
three
yes now how do we think about this from
the quasi-hyperbolic discounting model
how do we explain this behavior
this
yeah exactly so let me just repeat what
you what you said so you said you know
people think they will not borrow in the
future
they're like i'm going to borrow for a
while i'm going to borrow for a few
months i just need some money right now
in the future surely i'll be patient i
pay everything back um
and so no it doesn't really matter what
the interest rate is after six months
uh therefore i'm just going to optimize
according to the
the uh six months period that i see the
you know the third deal is uh uh cheaper
than the second so let me just pick that
and then so the surprise
people actually then keep borrowing and
uh it ends up being a lot more expensive
than
it is that's exactly right that's what i
have here um
as well now if people are sophisticated
why would they choose um
option two
yes
right so there's sort of the idea that
essentially if you don't like your
future self to borrow
you might want to actually choose a high
interest rate sort of could
to protect you from doing that now
that's a very sophisticated sort of type
of behavior
my guess is at the end of the day
that'll not be particularly um
successful because at the end of the day
the two percent different is probably
not making a huge difference but in
principle
the data is sort of consistent with that
we cannot rule this out
um now there's other issues with like
substitution to other cards and so on so
you might sort of
you might that might backfire in various
other ways but in principle at least you
know
um uh that's exactly right now
what evidence can we collect to separate
these stories if so i show you these
data from the paper
from uh that they have now i can't as
i'm telling you i'm can't really
disentangle these stories because
there's no
other data available but what other data
would you want to know or would you like
to collect to sort of disentangle from
these two stories
or disentangle these two stories
people yes borrowing so you could look
at their
borrowing behavior and then what would
you conclude or what data what would you
um
yes i think that's something i think
it's a little inconclusive in some sense
but yes i think that's that's right
um what else can we collect
yes
yes exactly so if you ask people like
what do you think you're going to do
that would be helpful and then you know
in some ways it will also be nice to
have some form of like demand for
commitment
we don't quite have this here because
there's sort of neither of these options
is actually
uh dominated right you could sort of
tell stories either way
but once you have um a dominated option
the naive person would not pick that
anymore
i think it's also right that like
looking at sort of people's borrowing
behavior we can also learn from that in
some sense
it can't be that like you keep sort of
uh doing stuff that's bad for you if
you're really sophisticated
um uh but sort of
sorry so two things i think that are
uh uh you can sort of click collect
potentially collect clear-cut evidence
to real stuff out is
one uh collect beliefs about for
following uh
boring behavior so there's one very nice
paper recent paper by
uh hunt alcott and uh dmitry chabinsky
and and co-authors
that looks at payday borrowers this is
like payday lending at really extremely
high interest rates where people
essentially borrow against their future
paycheck
and they keep doing this over and over
again and what they do there they
actually elicit people's beliefs and say
um what do you think is the probability
that you're gonna borrow again
you can ask that many people several
people and then essentially just look at
like what's what are the actual beliefs
uh sorry about the actual uh borrowing
rates about what fraction of people are
actually borrowing again
compared to like the perceived fraction
um
and what they find in fact is payday
borrowers seem to be quite sophisticated
so these are people who like
actually no i'm gonna like borrow again
in like um uh
uh uh two weeks from now and so on and
then i'm gonna roll it over and over
again
now they also find that um that is more
common
uh among repeat borrowers so like
somebody who has like rolled us over
five times
they actually don't have a lot of
illusions of like uh uh what they're
gonna do in the future they know they're
gonna roll it over again
when you look at people who are like
first time or second time borrowers
things are different uh
there people tend to think i'm going to
do this only once or twice
and then you know they sort of surprise
themselves um
by borrowing and that's sort of
consistent with some story of learning
and isn't so like they don't
necessarily they can't really
necessarily nail that but i think they
find essentially that
or they interpret their evidence as
people do seem to be uh learning over
time
um they also offer some form of
commitment device essentially they offer
them to say if you don't borrow again
um uh uh you know uh uh we'll pay you a
hundred dollars or like uh
versions of that or like you have to pay
or you can forego money
if you uh not borrow if commit to not
borrowing again
um they also find some uh evidence of
that sort of suggesting that
again these payday borrowers seem to be
quite uh sophisticated now that's
of course the different type of sample
um a different type of population
so you know credit card people
particularly who get credit card
mailings
in particular people who just started
their jobs and so on and so forth
might be uh not as sophisticated now
if you're a credit card company what
would you do how would you react to that
kind of behavior suppose you believe
what i showed you earlier the evidence
that i just showed you about
from the ausubil paper in terms of like
people seem to be
either naive or sophisticated quasi
hyperbolic discounters
what do you do as a credit card company
whom do you target and how do you do it
yes perhaps you could map some kind of
characteristic of the person maybe
demographics like
education or socioeconomic uh
characteristics with
possible naive slash sophisticated and
then
almost christ well not quite involved
i want to target each person based on
those characteristics so the
sophisticated person would have
the lower uh teaser ratio than the
higher
interest rate towards the end and you
could do the same for
those who are nice right exactly so what
you kind of want to know is in some
sense
you want to know who who are the naive
peace people who are the people that we
can essentially
exploit right because the naive person
is the person who's going to be the
person who who signs up
and then ends up paying really high
interest rates surprisingly
so you can essentially uh figure out
some ways of making a lot of money
from them the exponential discount or so
even the sophisticated people
they will not be helpful for you because
either they both just essentially just
optimize in some sense they use sort of
some offers they get some bonus
points or whatever for like signing up
in the first place and then essentially
just drop the card or not use it anymore
even the sophisticated person you can't
really exploit that much because like
if you call the sophisticated person
would sort of understand that
and then would just not sign up in the
first place right and this is kind of
the answer to
what lauren just said uh about like if
somebody if you can make a lot of money
from that person
it can't be that that person is
perfectly sophisticated
because then otherwise the person would
never sort of sign up in the first place
now um credit card companies exactly
there's some evidence at least that
credit card companies do exactly what
you just said
which essentially is so they don't have
a lot of information of people that they
actually mail to
the one thing that they have is sort of
zip code uh
level information very often about like
education and some other characteristics
from some other data sets
so there's a very nice paper by um rue
and shore antoinette schwarz
at sloan um at mit um that looks at
analyze like detailed
detailed data set of like mailed credit
card offers so they essentially are
people who are paid to collect all the
mailings that they get from
different companies and just collect
them and sort of uh
uh have them analyzed and there's a sort
of a data set doing that exactly that
and so what did what they did is they
analyzed this data set specifically
and looked at um how some of the details
of these offers
relate to things like education zip code
so you could look at sort of education
level data like who are where
do the highly educated people live and
where where do other people live
and what they find is that education
levels are systematically related to
things like
backloaded and hidden fees um teasers
or like stuff that's like written in
small font
having more photos color print and so on
and so forth essentially a bunch of
stuff that's trying to trick people
into um uh uh sort of things that are
bad for them
so what the credit card companies are
doing they essentially sort of say
here's some stuff that
is exploiting uh potentially uh naive
customers
no you'd only want to send that kind of
stuff to uh naive people are mostly to
to
to naive or or less sophisticated uh
customers
the reason being that like a it's costly
to do it so if you send it to
you know um people who are exponential
discounters who are sophisticated you're
just wasting money
or you know they might actually exploit
sort of your offer by sort of optimizing
and sort of
getting good deals out of it in in some
ways so what you kind of want to do is
you want to focus on the naive
customers and sort of exploit them as
much as you can
now actually it's not that you want to
exploit them as much as you can there
are some constraints what are sort of
the constraints here what is the credit
card company in some ways worried about
yes
exactly so that this is a pretty cynical
view of the world but i think it's a
pretty um
correct one in some ways which is the
credit card company wants to exploit
people but only to the extent that they
can actually
repay the last thing the credit card
company wants is for people to default
not because the credit card company
actually cares about the people who
might default
but rather because the credit card
company has then trouble actually
getting their money um
back right so there's essentially like
some form of like a participation
constraint
and so what um uh rue and sure find is
that
at times and there's maybe this is like
suggestive evidence but it's pretty um
neat in some way at times when
unemployment insurance
um uh uh uh sort of from the government
uh increase so essentially as more as
more people have like more money
available
a lot of these fees etc are tend to be
higher
and so one way to interpret that is
essentially there's a participation
constraint if you want an
optimization problem is to say you know
they try to exploit the customers but
like it's subject to like
the constraint that the person doesn't
default or just doesn't use the offers
at all
now that participation constraint gets
sort of relaxed because you know now
that
people like due to unemployment and
other types of insurance
have more money available so essentially
you can exploit them
more this is sort of like a pattern i
think that's
general that's general for many uh cases
i think when you for example think about
like gyms
you might sort of say well people choose
in gyms
the offers that gyms give to people uh
in a way they are meant to exploit
customers or do you really want what i
showed you last time is you really want
to offer people like these like okay you
can
monthly fees or whatever like you want
people to sign up
but then actually not show up very much
to your gym because you know then you
have
you don't have a certain capacity you
don't hit your gym capacity
but you know some people might then say
well why not just ask people like
to give them even more and more
expensive contracts that they sign up
so they really sort of to screw them
over uh more and more
the problem is like there's again like a
participation constraint
if the person sort of realizes i'm
spending way too much money on this
and i'm not actually going to the gym
ever the person is just going to quit
right so you kind of want a days out of
this game where essentially you want
your customer to be engaged you want
your customer to sort of
come back sometimes and feel good about
going to the gym sometimes and not feel
terrible about not coming
so that's why attention the the gyms and
other companies are always trying to be
very motivating we choose the best
contract for you we're trying to help
you with this and that
but really it's sort of in some sense
making the appearance of trying to help
the customers
keeping them happy while you can exploit
them at the same time
now that's a very cynical view of the
world and i'm sure there are some
companies who actually care about their
customers
but in some sense i think it can explain
quite a few patterns that we see
in the world any questions on this
or comments
okay so then next is um and this is sort
of like again like a
um almost like a classic paper now
because it's been quite a while ago
uh it's a paper by nava ashraf and
colleagues in the philippines
these are clients of a philippine bank
and they are randomized uh
to um uh be uh
into three different groups to be
receiving uh
three different or kinds of uh savings
product
the first one is essentially like um a
very simple or sorry the first one
number three is like a control treatment
which is a
standard savings account here's an
account that you can open and
uh you're going to get some uh some
interest rate for
uh saving in this account the second one
is like a marketing treatment which
essentially is encouraging people to
sign up
uh otherwise it's like the same
essentially saying like trying to get
people to to to do it
uh number one and this is i guess sort
of the the treatment of interest is
what's called the seed treatment which
is uh encouraging people to sign up plus
a commitment offer which is
clients can restrict their access to the
deposits upon opening the account
so what you can essentially do is you
can set some goals
these goals are either date based or
amount based so you can say
i want to save a thousand dollars or
like some amount
and until i've reached that amount i
cannot withdraw any money
alternatively you can say i would like
to save until my husband's or my wife's
a birthday or some other child's
graduation or whatever you want to say
for christmas etc
and only then we can uh i will draw the
money as you can see most people seem to
be choosing
um sort of date-based types of gold but
others also have um
amount based you can see about 70
here date based and 30 are uh amount
based
now what they find is a there's quite a
bit of take up of this account
and again like when you think about this
like there's not a good reason to to
to take up this account unless you want
to sort of restrict your
um your future self so there's sort of
some demand
some evidence of demand for commitment
second offering this kind of account uh
increases people's savings so on average
people save more i'm going to tell you a
little bit about the distribution of
that is actually everybody better off
from doing that
but on average people do save more so
essentially it's kind of similar to the
evidence that i showed you earlier
commitment devices at least on average
can improve outcomes or affect
outcomes in some way and then number
three um and that's a little bit
suggestive but essentially saying like
if you sort of look at money now versus
later question that i showed you earlier
in the class
they actually do predict uh commitment
take up consistent with some form of
like uh this is really about uh time
preferences as opposed to maybe other
things like
demand effect social desirability buyers
essentially like
customers maybe just wanting to make the
bank happy in some way because they feel
compelled to do it because they get like
some marketing treatment
and a particularly strong one any
questions on this
no this is uh i think it's uh taking it
i think it's taking up and putting some
money in it yeah i think the take-up
is put in like once you put in some
money it's counted as using the or
taking up the account otherwise it would
be like yeah that's not
not really anything essentially
restricting your choices in some way by
putting in some
some money into this account
okay so next to some work that i've done
in india on alcohol consumption and sort
of
this is a very common issue among
low-income workers
in south india and tamonado and kerala
and other places
it's also an issue in other countries in
uganda
and so on so there's large fractions of
low-income workers
drink a large amount of alcohol often
daily
what do i mean by that they drink
something like five six standard drinks
um per day what's the standard drinks
it's like a small a beer
or like a shot of liquor so five things
six standard rings are a lot of
alcohol now they also spend a large
amount of their
money of the income on alcohol on the
order of magnitude of 20 30 40 percent
so think of these as like families of
five or six um
uh sorry families of uh four or five
often
uh what they earn is something like 300
400 rupees
per day that's usually often the family
income some earn a little bit more
that's something like five six seven
dollars per day and often they spend one
or two dollars on alcohol
right and so um when you now ask people
when you ask women when you ask men
about like you know how does alcohol
affect your lives you get sort of this
uniform response of people saying like
well only if only liquor stores closed
my life would be so much better
um you know i would love for liquor
prices to be higher
and you know i would like to find some
way to reduce my drinking but i have
trouble uh doing so
when you now ask people like okay now
you would like to reduce your drinking
it would be great for you the liquor
stores because
why is it difficult for you to reduce
your drinking
the common response is also a addiction
which makes things tricky anyway
but b um they say people say they have
physical pain
and so the physical pain from work
particularly these are people with very
low
levels of education so often they're
literate and so on so it's very hard for
them to get any desk job or the like
so what instead they um have to do is
essentially do physical labor hard
physical labor these are like
construction workers rickshaw drivers
uh sewage workers and so on and so forth
this is really hard work
and uh they tend to have then lots of
physical pain uh from their work
now why is it that then like the pain
exacerbates potentially people's
self-control problems why is that making
things worse
yes
now
right so what you're saying essentially
is there's uh uh you can do
self-medicating physical pain in
addition to maybe some other reasons
social reasons and so on
it turns out in these kind of in this
setting at least specifically people
tend to not drink so much for social
reasons there's like some social
function there's like funerals or other
sort of like
festivals with people where lots of
people drink but they're drinking a
particular mixture of drivers is often
like people drink on their own
essentially to numb their pain in some
ways now when you think about like
self-control problems
uh often where self-control problems
arrive if you
arise is when you have short-run
benefits and long-run costs
right essentially that's sort of like
the consumption good that people over
consume
now when you think about like physical
pain what does physical pain do it
it very much increases the short-run
benefits of drinking while keeping
long-run costs or anything else
uh constant but in sort of if you think
about like you have lots of short-run
benefits now of drinking
because there's lots of pain that
alcohol helps numbing
and alcohol is a very powerful
anesthetic as it turns out
so then essentially it sort of increases
the short-run benefits and that's sort
of the
short-run desire to to drink and then
any long-run costs about like health and
so on and so forth
are very much in the future uh uh and
that's where essentially the
self-control problem potentially
arises um now people not only drink a
lot
um overall in in chennai and and
surrounding areas
but they drink also quite a bit in
particular rickshaw drivers during the
day
so what i was doing there is essentially
just randomly or like
walking around in chennai or or alright
would do that i'm
walking around in chennai and just
breathalyzing people more or less
randomly
offering them essentially would you like
to do a breathalyzer test and
for some small amount regardless of the
result is and
about half of these rickshaw drivers and
these are all cycle rickshaws so they
you know
it's not particularly dangerous to do
that but about half of them
are showing positive breathalyzer stores
essentially half of them at least
somewhat enumerated
about 20 25 percent are or are pretty
drunk
sort of as in like their blood alcohol
content is about point
uh 0.1 or higher which is you know above
the u.s legal driving limit
overall now this is during the regular
work hours these are people who are
actually at work
now then sort of seeing that and sort of
having people report about their
self-control problem i was answered
wondering okay now
what kinds of commitment devices could
we perhaps perhaps offer to people to
reuse the drinking
given that they tend to report
self-control problems or
physical pain or self-control problems
related to physical pain
are a key issue and sort of preventing
them from reducing their drinking
if they desire to do so of course what
what could we do
yes
yes so we could essentially exactly so
you could essentially say i'm going to
try and find you
i'm going to call you sometimes randomly
and uh
you get some reward if you're sober so
essentially incentivizing people to be
sober that's exactly right you could
do that now is that a so what would it
be a commitment device what
would like a commitment device for that
look like so what you just mentioned is
essentially just providing people
incentives incentivizing them and that
could truly work
uh how would i sort of show that these
are in fact self-control problems or
people have
quasi-hyperbolic or or similar
preferences
right essentially you have to give
people choices and some poise choices
are potentially dominated so
what does that mean i'm giving you some
choices here's i'm you can choose to
either receive the incentives
and you only receive these incentives if
you're sober alternatively i'm going to
just pay you
some amount and that amount ideally is
like higher than the amount that you
could get from
these incentives now then if you choose
the incentives what does that mean
essentially that means you want to
increase your future prices of drinking
that would be essentially demand for a
commitment
now the other thing we could potentially
do is what i showed you earlier which is
the drug that's called ant abuse which
essentially is a drug that you can take
to prevent yourself from being able to
metabolize alcohol
i was actually thinking about that for
quite a while um the reason why i wasn't
doing that was
um the tricky part here is that once you
actually start drinking while you're on
this drug
that's very dangerous and uh so now in
particular if you have been drinking for
quite a while
withdrawal symptoms related to alcohol
are very dangerous so if
you have been drinking alcohol for 10 20
years like many of the people in the
sample have
now abruptly reducing your drinking is
dangerous because you can essentially
get
what's called the lyrum tremors tremens
like very sort of severe self-contra
uh very severe um withdrawal symptoms
that could even
uh you could even die from that now one
thing you can do is when you get like uh
withdrawal symptoms you can actually
start drinking and that helps
now the problem is like when you have
taken antibiotics you can't do that
so essentially there's sort of the
issues and then you get this alcohol and
abuse rela uh
reaction which is really bad so it ended
up
not doing that for various ethical and
other reasons but what i did do is
essentially give people
the option of dominated choices so
so what does the experiment look like
it's a three-week field experiment with
with the rickshaw drivers uh in in
chennai we
um didn't sort of do the random
breathalyzing in the sort of field in
part because that was really
it's really hard to actually find people
if they're sort of roaming around on the
rickshaw and
everybody has their phone or answers
their phone and so on so instead we ask
people to come to the study office
between six and p.m six and ten pm
every day it's between six and ten pm
because breathalyzer tests can tell you
about drinking during the previous
something like six to ten hours
right so if i if you breathalyze me now
what you can tell us what i have been
drinking in the last let's say eight
hours or something
you cannot really tell what i've been
drinking yesterday right so if we did
the breathalyzer test in the morning
that would not be particularly helpful
because it
really it can't tell you very much about
the drinking on the previous
day and then uh we provided financial
incentives for sobriety for a subset of
individuals what do these financial
incentives look like
they look very simple and sometimes very
similar to what you just suggested
so option a or these are the financial
incentives are people are given
60 rupees which is about a dollar just
for showing up so just come to the
office
and show up do a breathalyzer test and
do some survey questions and you get
like a dollar for
doing that and then if your breathalyzer
score is zero
you get another dollar 120 rupees
that's essentially the incentives for uh
sobriety
now option b and sort of this is people
were given
choices for that option b was there was
like three different versions of that
the first one is where option b was 90
rupees which essentially is come to the
office and you can choose to get 90
rupees just come to the office
whenever you show up you get 90 rupees
regardless of what your breathalyzer
score
is you are breathalyzed but it doesn't
matter what your score is for your
payment
now when you choose the incentives over
option b is that a commitment device
or how do we think about this choice
what do we learn from that choice
bye
so let me let me give you an example of
a person who might choose this
suppose there's a person who is actually
mostly sober
as an exponential discounter and wants
to be drunk just once a week so these
are sorry these are choices for six days
for like the following week
so the person is perfectly rational the
person has perfect foresights and knows
that they're going to be drunk once next
week
and they're going to choose option a
right because they think it's a great
deal
and so they actually don't want any
commitment the only reason why they
choose that is because the expected
value of the money that they will get
will be higher if they are at least half
of the time sober
right so so so that choice in fact is
not a commitment device
however um moving towards like choices
two and three
now we get into like territory of
dominated contracts that in fact are
commitment devices
so the key part here is that when you
now look at the second choice
um when you choose now option a or row
option b
you can actually only do worse right the
only reason why you choose option a
is because you want to have incentives
now you risk showing up drunk
on some days in which case you get less
money but the
the benefit of that now is that now you
have these incentives so essentially you
want incentives
but what you take into account is that
potentially if you don't show up sober
all the time you might lose some money
so these we this kind of contract or
this type of choice
we call like a weekly dominated uh a
contract contractor choice
in terms of study payments so if people
choose
option a in the second choice that is
some demand for commitment
now when i look at the third choice now
option a
is like strictly dominated right so now
if you choose option a
uh you you will do worse for sure um in
terms of how much you will be paid
right you every day you get like 30
rupees which is about 10 of people's
daily incomes
every day you get 30 rupees less
and the benefit again is like incentives
um for sobriety so if you want to choose
these incentives
that'll be costly for you for sure um
and now you have to sort of weigh
whether you uh
like those or not so um what i find is
and what you see here is essentially um
the fraction of people choosing
incentives for
choice one two and three so in black you
see choice one which is a 90 rupees
choice
uh and dark blue you see um uh uh uh the
120 rupees choice you saw the weekly
dominated choices
and then you see an uh in light blue the
uh
150 rupees um choices these are this uh
uh
strictly dominated choices and there's
like three weeks and we will do this so
each week they choose for the following
week
uh what incentives do you like to set
themselves for the next uh six days
okay so these are the three uh options
again uh
and uh you see the choices over time so
what we find
is or what i find is that in fact quite
a few people about half of the
individuals choose the incentives when
they're weakly dominated which is sort
of some evidence of demand for
commitment
but perhaps more strikingly about a
third of individuals choose the
incentives when they're strictly
dominated
so these are people who are willing to
to forego three times in a row like you
know
not just once but like in the second
week and also in the third week and if
anything the fraction of people choosing
these incentives
goes up over time people are willing to
choose these incentives
and willing to give up about 10 of their
daily incomes uh
for like an entire week uh to receive
incentives to be sober
so that's very strong evidence of um
demand for commitment
now what we also find is when you sort
of randomize just the incentives
themselves um uh for some people versus
unconditional payments overall
these incentives are in fact successful
and reducing people's day drinking so
people actually show up more
um uh sober um when they receive
incentives
however as you might have expected as
well the problem is like
the the breathalyzer incentivizes the
during the day like the time before 6
and 10 p.m before people come to the
study office
it is not incentivizing sort of the the
time after this in the evening
and as you sort of this is some work by
you know homestay if you
have multitasking at sort of different
times of the day or different actions
that you can take
if you incentivize one thing what often
happens people follow these incentives
but then they sort of substitute to
other things in their life
so then what in fact happens that people
overall people's overall drinking does
not
decrease very much so while people seem
to have quite a bit of demand for
these incentives in fact you know um it
is helpful for increasing their daytime
sobriety
but not helpful for decreasing their um
overall drinking
so then i was looking at sort of the
impact of that treatment in a sense like
now people are sober more sober during
the day
in fact somewhat surprisingly i find
very little evidence on labor market
outcomes it's not actually people are
working
better but i do find people make
different savings decisions people are
willing to save a lot more um when
they're sober even when you take into
account that they also might have more
money
overall at least money more money
available yes
so um so i spent quite a bit of time
thinking about demand effects and sort
of making sure that people are
sometimes people in this setting um have
much less
uh concerns about what other people
think when they drink they're very happy
to tell you yesterday i drank
uh a six six strings uh they're also
very happy to tell you like yesterday i
spent a third of my income on alcohol
and so on
people are very open about this so it's
not like people misreport in surveys and
so on
um people's reported drinking is also
very much like consistent with the
actual breathalyzer score so if you sort
of match that up in terms of how much
have you been drinking today versus what
the breathalyzer score says
that seems consistent as well now there
are some studies looking at sort of
social desirability bias and demand
effects and often what you find is that
when choices are not incentivized when
they have very weak incentives there is
often evidence for for demand effect and
social desirability bias
but when you make things very costly in
a sense of like this is a very costly
thing for you to do
to just make the experimenter happy we
spend a lot of time essentially being
very clear about like you can do
whatever you want and so on and so forth
and what we tend to find is that in the
first few days people seem slightly
uncomfortable in this
there's more to the study but there's
like a baseline period of about a week
in the first few days people seem to be
slightly uncomfortable of being drunk in
the office and so on and so forth and
sort of breathaly having positive
breathalyzer scores
uh that goes away very quickly so people
are very happy to show up
as drunk as they uh they are so i think
overall i would you know think if this
is one choice and you're like maybe
people are making mistakes or people
maybe
want to make you happy you know once you
make that choice once for a whole week
you get essentially a lot less money
than you would get otherwise
you make that choice again again you get
like for a whole week a lot less money
than you would otherwise
and then people choose it yet again so
like you know while i can't entirely
rule out this explanation uh there's a
discussion of that in the paper
but i can't rule out this entirely it
seems unlikely at least in the
second and third choice given that it's
really really costly um
for people
they know
right so the second question is like
okay now why are people making these
choices so one
uh broad question is like okay uh
so when talking to people a lot of
people would say well
um they would come be like oh last week
you know
it was really difficult and didn't
really succeed and so on and then they
were like from tomorrow onwards things
will be different so there's lots of
people who in fact
seem naive in the sense of like they
really think going forward they will um
they will change their behavior often i
think what they are
reasonably clear about is how often they
will actually be sober
um going forward what they have trouble
with is essentially predicting their
behavior later in the day so they seem
to think like okay tomorrow i'm not
going to drink and then i'm also going
to
not going to drink at nights that
doesn't seem to change
now there's a second explanation that's
also in the paper and discussed in more
detail that i can't really necessarily
rule out
there are actually some benefits of
reducing people's drinking these are all
kind of like small benefits but they
actually sort of add up
so one part of that is savings people
save a lot more money they get more
interest from saving that's actually
quite a bit of money that they make from
that
so they potentially make better
decisions second they have like so
while it's not significant people have
somewhat higher um earnings people also
have somewhat reduced costs of
drinking and so on so there's some
essentially evidence of like
several benefits that in the order of
magnitude are like 5-10 rupees per day
so when you have like somewhat increased
earnings somewhat reduced expenditures
and alcohol
increased savings and then on top of
that people would also tell you they
like to be what they say like a sober
man is all men
they like to be a sober man and sort of
have some value of actually sobriety
um during the day so i think it's a
mixture my guess is we've had to best
explain the evidence that we have it's a
mixture of
there actually being some evidence of um
benefits of being sober that you can
weigh against like 30 rupees
a a loss of lost uh foregone uh
benefits from the study uh and there's
also some naivete in a sense of
people's there are people's beliefs
about wanting to
drink glass also um in the evening and
that's just not necessarily working out
i want to say another comment to this
which is when you see people choosing
commitment devices
that fail you can't necessarily rule out
that
people are reasonably sophisticated the
reason being like for example if i were
a smoker that smoked a lot and the value
of me
stopping to smoke is really high suppose
i think you know if i just could stop
smoking i would live like five years
longer that's a huge value in terms of
like the benefits
if somebody came to me and said there's
a commitment device with a one percent
chance it's going to work
would you like to buy it and it costs
100
i might actually choose this commitment
device
because it's sort of the expected value
of that is actually higher
even if like 99 of the cases i'm
actually going to fail
so then you looking at the data you
might say look these people are
essentially making a bunch of mistakes
but i think from their perspective it's
rather they have been drinking for so
long they struggle with this and they
try to reduce their drinking
there is a chance that maybe this will
work maybe it will not so let me really
try and do this
and see unfortunately as it turns out
it's in fact not successful at least
when
when it comes to their um uh drinking
overall
okay um second speaking of smoking uh
has a second paper on commitment devices
relative
related to sort of addictive products
this is um
a voluntary commitment product for
smoking cessation smokers are offered a
non-standard savings account this is the
same
setting as in the philippines where uh
these are
clients of a bank these are smokers so
like selecting on
actually somebody being a smoker and
they are offered a the following
commitment device you can deposit
funds for six months uh and then you can
take a urine test for uh nicotine and
coutine which apparently tests pretty
well whether you have been drinking who
have been sorry not been smoking for the
last uh week or so or a bit longer
if you pass you get the money back
that's in your account if you fail
the money is gone essentially now do we
think is this a good commitment contract
or do we like this or not or how do we
think about this commitment contract
yes
yeah so so exactly you could lose quite
a bit of money and make people quite
unhappy
but do we think you know
is this actually suppose you were
sophisticated would you sign up or or
how would you
how would you behave like suppose i
offered you the contract you have it now
what would you do
right so you put money in it but i think
so one key part here is that
the actual quitting only occurs until
like six months from now
right is to say like it's sort of a
little bit of a funny thing in the sense
of saying like look
you really want to quit smoking it's
like in six months from now
now you already have lots of long run
benefits uh sorry lots of long run costs
of like smoking which is you know
lung cancer like other health issues and
so on and so forth
now i'm sort of adding some of like a
long run incentives in like six months
from now
which is a little bit far away so what
it sort of needs is
it's sort of in a way you would not
start quitting to smoke right away you
would say well in five months from now i
can sort of stop
and now of course you can then sort of
build your own commitment device by
putting
a in a lot of money and then sort of
really ramping up these incentives
but in some sense what you kind of want
is a commitment device that like i sign
up for it i'm like really excited to
stop smoking
and now you want to sort of provide
incentives almost like right away to
to get people going but instead it's
sort of this commitment device that
requires quite a bit of
sophistication in a sense of saying like
now i know that in like six months from
now i want to stop smoking i kind of
don't want to
stop smoking right now i can always do
it tomorrow because people like to delay
depending on how they are and so on and
so
you know i can see lots of people and
saying oh yeah in three months from now
i'm gonna do it
and then i'm gonna put in some money and
so on but they end up not doing it uh
eventually it turns out in empirically
it works like reasonably well in a sense
there's like 10 percent of
pickup like 10 of people actually put in
some money there is also like
um an impact on smoking of three
percentage point that sounds kind of
small
uh but you know that's actually pretty
sizable in terms of like getting people
to stop smoking is pretty hard
they also these effects persist and
surprise tests like 12 months later so
when you sort of surprise people later
and sort of say hey surprise he's a test
uh uh you get some money for doing it
turns out that like people who got this
commitment
uh offered this commitment uh uh smoking
a
contract or product are in fact less
likely
to smoke
okay now a second question or related to
that is to say
if people are um unhappy about their
smoking in the future if people would
like to reduce their futures
future smoking there's sort of some
arguments that
taxes can be some form of not quite
commitment devices but
ways in which you could reduce your
smoking
so the rickshaw drivers in chennai would
sort of tell me i would love to
for alcohol prices to be more expensive
because that would sort of help me
reduce my drinking so if they could sort
of set prices
quite a few people would say i would set
prices really high so that would help me
reduce
my drinking so if people could choose
their own prices and if they would set
high prices that would be essentially a
form of a commitment device
to reduce your uh smoking or drinking
so um when you look at smokers there's
lots of people who
say they would like to quit about eight
out of ten
u.s smokers say that if you have a
friend to smoke you you will
get those common patterns as lots of
people say i would love to quit
lots of quit attempts that often are not
successful
now one way you can sort of reduce
smoking potentially is or
accomplish your goal is to say like
prices might be higher
again like uh higher prices essentially
that sort of like hot
the law of demand like you know uh
prices go up people smoke less
and that's true for smoking drinking as
well and so that that might help curb
people's
uh self-control problems now one simple
question that um
john gruber who's in the economics
department and senator mulanathan uh
we're asking is like well once we
increase
taxes now smoker is actually happier
right and so if it's true that people
have self-control problems
people um uh people might be happier
because it helps them essentially reduce
their smoking
it helps them deal with their
self-control problems um you could even
say like once prices become infinitely
expensive as long as people can't
substitute in certain ways or got around
these
these sort of um rules they might even
be happy about banning smoking because
that would be the simplest way of
getting rid of their smoking habit if
they really want to do so
now um ruber and mulanathan have like an
empirical test of this in the west and
canada
and uh in fact when you look at the
division over time higher
cigarette taxes are associated with
higher self-reported well-being
in particular among those who are likely
smokers right
now you could also say well other people
are happier as well but that's not that
interesting because you know there's
externalities from smoking
and if you are not a smoker you should
be happy about smoking taxes
a because they're going to reduce your
externalities people are going to smoke
less in your face and you might sort of
like that
uh second there's going to be revenues
from taxation you're also going to be
very happy if other people pay higher
taxes
right so but what they do is they look
at essentially uh
households particularly that are likely
smokers and sort of
that helps then sort of identify um or
that's a much more interesting result
than like households who are non-smokers
there's some caveat that some of the
respondents might be spouses of the
actual smokers
again that's sort of in some sense less
interesting from the uh sort of beta
delta perspective
because you know if a husband or wife
wants to get their spouse to smoke glass
they might be quite happy about it
but it's more like because the spouse
thinks the uh
their husband or wife have a
self-control problem as opposed to
they have one uh themselves or it could
be even like for
lack of self-control problems could just
be the husband like smoking the wife
does not if prices go up uh the husband
might still
smoke less and the wife might be happy
or the other way around
and nothing to do with self-control
problem just like if prices go up people
consume stuff
less to be clear such effects are not
possible and not consistent
with sort of exponential discounting
because you have an exponential
discounter you would either
smoke because you like smoking or you
would not smoke there's no scenario in
which you are smoking but you really
would like to
to quit if you would like to quit and if
it's worth for you to quit you would
actually do that
so you would not be happy about higher
prices the same way as you would not be
happy about higher prices for apple and
apples and bananas people don't like
high prices because essentially they
have to pay more and that sort of
reduces their
budget any questions on this
yes
um yes so one i think you're bringing up
a very good point
which is um often uh a big discussion
for
uh so-called like sin taxes which is
essentially
uh uh uh taxes on either cigarettes on
on
alcohol on uh sodas and so on
uh so there's different um objectives
often one is essentially helping people
who are potentially have self-control
problems second there's sort of
redistribution
redistribution as a as a sort of goal or
like a problem in some sense
and that's the same case in in india in
some sense
if you increase alcohol prices in india
on the one hand people would
drink less but the elasticity of
drinking tends to be fairly low
meaning that like if you increase the
price of alcohol or cigarettes or the
like by one percent usually
uh the consumption only reduces by less
than one percent
which means that overall expenditures
while people actually drink or smoke
less overall expenditure
expenditures actually go up right and so
if you're worried about the poor then in
particular
a they tend to uh consume these types of
goods more when it comes to smoking
drinking
but also sodas in particular in the in
the u.s
when you're worried then about uh sort
of increasing uh taxes and then sort of
expenditures and then essentially having
a particular high burden
uh among the poor so then uh
there's questions on how to deal with
that so one potential uh um
way to do this would be sort of in some
sense to refund then the taxes that
actually incurred in particular then in
some form of transfers
that's often not necessarily feasible
but exactly that's that's exactly the
problem when you think about like for
example soda taxes there's a very nice
paper by dimitri tabinski on hunt
alcohol and so on i can add this to the
to the slides
uh that essentially looking exactly that
in the us uh when you think about soda
taxes
how do you deal with like two different
objectives one is uh helping people to
to
consume less sodas if they desire to do
so um and second kind of redistribution
dealing with the fact that the burden is
particularly high among the poor in
terms of like
how much money to pay you kind of want
it to be the opposite you want like the
rich to people
pay more taxes uh rather than the poor
and some of these taxes do the opposite
and then there's a question like how do
you weigh these two objectives and how
do you can maybe undo some of the
effects that you're doing
yes
i think these are like simple uh uh uh
these are just simple
surveys like about people's happiness
and so on and so forth
is that your question or no
[Music]
oh i think this is just trying to
predict it using uh using
uh um their demographics so i think they
don't
so that one of the key this is the key
weakness of the study is like two things
they just do not have data on like does
the respondent
actually smoke so they only know like
essentially household characteristics
how rich are they
and so on and so forth from like
essentially a bunch of survey questions
but there's no actual question uh of
like do you smoke
or not and so that's why in part this
paper in fact is not
published in the top journal the reason
being that exactly that's the issue like
a
um you don't actually know whether the
person smokes b
it could be that it's a spouse of a
smoker that's that's answering the
question so we kind of know that the
propensity of that household to smoke
from like other data sets when we try to
just predict smoking using these
demographics
is high but we don't actually know when
the specific cases are people smoking
which makes it sort of vulnerable to
these kinds of
concerns yeah
okay let me um talk briefly about a
fertilizer and then
summarize a little bit the evidence that
we saw so this is a paper by esther
duflo and michael kramer who recently
won the nobel prize
in economics uh esther floyd's in the
economics department
at mit as well michael kramer is at
harvard it's a people with john robinson
um from 2011 in the ar
um what this paper looks at is
fertilizer used in western kenya
and sort of this is one of these
technologies and developing countries
where there's quite a bit of evidence
and people think the returns to using
fertilizer are
high right that's a thing that farmers
could use essentially would increase
your yields the returns are on the order
of magnitude of like 50 100 percent
uh often over the course of like a few
months so it's a really highly
profitable profitable type of investment
it's also like a divisible investment
it's not like a cow or like a tractor or
something where you have to save a lot
of money to actually buy it
this is a thing where you can buy like a
kilo or five kilos whatever fertilizer
you can lose like very small amounts of
um
of money and sort of then start saving
and if the returns are really that high
you know people should just using it
then become richer um over time
now uh there's a persistent sort of
finding that fertilizer used in
particular in sub-saharan africa
tends to be low including in western
kenya in the area of this study
now one explanation that people often
say is that
farmers would like to purchase
fertilizer when you ask them around the
time of harvest which is when they have
a lot of money so these harvest cycles
farmers like a farm maize in this area
when you ask them around the time of
harvest when people have lots of money
and ask them about their plans to
purchase fertilizer they would say oh
yeah i'd love to
purchase fertilizer it's great and so on
and so forth but then uh
lots of stuff comes up lots of expenses
pile up school fees and like
friends ask for money and like you know
other festivals and so on and so forth
so then when the actual new season comes
when the planting time or the top
dressing time comes when the maze is a
little bit higher and you're supposed to
add fertilizer
to your maids then people don't have any
money left
now one way to overcome this issue is
essentially the best kind of commitment
in some sense is to just sort of do the
thing that you're planning to do
and that's exactly kind of what they're
doing this experiment so what they're
doing is they vary the
timing of the purchase decision and
offer people time limited discounts
around the time of harvest
so around the time of harvest they give
like a very small discount and say
you can essentially buy fertilizer and
that's going to be delivered to you
around the time of harvest but you have
to buy it right now
and they get these different forms of
discounts but essentially the discounts
tend to be small
and the key part here is that these
discounts are time-limited as in like
it's only around the time of harvest
so you can only do it right now you
cannot procrastinate in any way and say
oh
next week or in two weeks or three weeks
from now i'm gonna do it and so that's
essentially a form of a commitment
device in the sense of like
in some ways the best commitment device
so if you want something to get done you
can just do it and then you're
essentially done
so people do these early purchases of
fertilizer
and nobody sort of resells it or they're
like that's just another thing people do
in principle they could obviously do
that
but that's tends to be not the case and
what they find in this and
they find very large effects of this uh
type of commitment device or the early
purchase option
even when the discount is very small
very minor often it's just like delivery
to people's homes from the fertilizer
store which is not very hard to do
so even when this discount is relatively
small there's large effects on people's
fertilizer use and the effects are much
larger than like
offering people discounts around the
time of planting so they have another
condition where they say
around the time of planting when it when
when the time comes to actually use
fertilizer
they have a 50 discount around that time
but essentially that discount almost
does nothing
the reason being that when people have
run out of money it doesn't matter what
disco what the price is you catch
can't buy any fertilizer because you're
sort of cash constrained and can't buy
it
now that's a very interesting finding
and part for policy
because there's also quite a bit of
concerns about over adoption about
fertilizer subsidies being very
expensive and so on and so forth
and now when you provide time limited
discounts around the time of harvest
that are very small
you can potentially essentially not
spend a lot of money have large
increases in fertilizer use among the
people who have self-control problems
among the people who would actually like
to use fertilizer
if instead you provide discounts around
the time of planting
or 50 or higher a that's really
expensive to do and governments in
particular in in western kenya and kenya
or sub-saharan africa in general
tend to not have a lot of money so it's
a very expensive thing to do
plus you're also distorting a lot of
decisions among exponential discounters
right what you're doing is now i'm
giving you i'm making fertilizer much
cheaper for you
if you don't have a self-control problem
to start with you're going to overuse
fertilizer because now essentially a
fertilizer is like artificially cheap
for you
essentially so you push some people to
overuse fertilizer using an actual
discount
around the time of planting instead what
this policy does essentially gives like
very small discounts that are very cheap
and it only affects or mostly affects
people with self-control problems
those are the people who essentially
would sort of procrastinate buying
fertilizer they buy it right now
they don't spend a lot of money on it
and you could have potentially large
effects as they have shown
in this paper any questions on this
yeah do they do a part where they show
that
partners become more sophisticated no
they do they do not they have
essentially
one-shot decisions for farmers and uh
they sort of have some effects over the
course of several seasons but
it's essentially not the same choices
and so on
so this in some sense an early paper
that doesn't quite sort of uh look into
that
some of the work on like sophistication
and navitate sort of comes a little
later okay so let me briefly summarize
and talk a little bit about people
failing when it comes to using
commitment devices
so i have shown you several examples and
quite a few more examples of
demand for commitment and different
research studies these are all like
research studies that people have done
one way or the other
often there's a significant share of
people who demand commitment one way or
the other
that sort of says there's a significant
share of people who struggle with
self-control problems in some way and
they also are at least partially
sophisticated because they sort of
understand it and demand commitment
now there's also like a very high
variation variation in the fraction of
people demanding commitment
in some places it's very high as i
showed you in the alcohol examples and
then some other examples
um that i haven't necessarily shown you
uh and other examples like for example
in the smoking example and so on
demand for commitment tends to be
actually um quite low
so now why is that well we don't
actually know necessarily there's a few
sort of um explanations that people have
uh one of them is uncertainty people
might sort of be really worried about
the risk so if you have lots of
uncertainty in your life if you don't
know whether
next month you're going to be smoking or
not or you might have really really you
might have really stressful months next
month and you don't probably know
whether that's going to be stressful or
not
you might not want to choose a
commitment device because it's very
costly for you potentially
because you might start smoking again or
do other things
for reasons that are not necessarily
related to self-control it's just out of
your control
similarly for example in the data entry
example that i showed you people might
not choose
to have a positive target because
they're really worried about like risk
and in particular one characteristic
that was very much predictive of whether
people choose uh
these commitment devices whether they
have kids the reason being that like the
kids
they might be sick they might have like
really bad nights and so on and so forth
and uh uh so that sort of increases the
risk of like data entry
productivity uh uh in the future so one
uh part is like uncertainty a second
part is naivete partial naivety can get
people to not
uh purchase or demand certain commitment
devices
and ivt might vary quite a bit across
settings right it might be that like
um you might just be like a first-time
customer or first-time user of either
payday loans or of drinking and smoking
and so on you might be quite naive
in contrast in my setting in chennai
when i looked at
drinkers there are people i've been
drinking for many many years in some
sense they're not as naive
about their drinking at least overall um
another aspect is experience with
commitment devices and this is what your
question was about kind of like when you
provide people commitment devices maybe
it needs to require some learning over
time
and again like if you look at different
settings people have different types of
experience
overall we don't know the answer to
these questions in a sense we don't
actually know
exactly what's going on and why is
demand for commitment quite different
across settings
a second question that we don't really
know is like well so there are these
research studies that sort of look at
like commitment devices and say okay
commitment devices at least in theory
should help some people
um but we see actually very few uh real
world examples that actually help
um you know yesterday you mentioned some
of them that seem to be at least helpful
for
for some of you by the way if you could
email me those um i i'd like to collect
them and and report back to david lipson
who sort of says you know
uncertainty is the issue um uh but
we don't haven't really figured out in
some sense if if commitment devices were
really that great
you know you would think that it really
would take off there would be a company
would really make a lot of money with
with using them
there are some companies that we see in
the world but it's not really it can't
really say it has really fully taken off
perhaps some companies related to like
cell phone usage or computer uses and so
on
but it's not as sort of prevalent and
widely used as we we might expect
given the sort of the theory literature
that we have now one important part
that's that's really sort of another
potential
uh contributor to depressed demand for
commitment is that people
uh might not only be naive in the sense
that like they might not understand
the value of commitment devices and then
that might sort of prevent them from
taking them up
but even conditional on demanding
commitment they might fail
right and sort of there's a couple of
examples here for example in the
uh philippines savings accounts example
that i showed you the seed
commitment savings account and john has
a very nice paper that shows that
in fact when you look at the same
setting a similar experiment
offering people this commitment contract
has positive effects on people saving so
people do actually save more on average
compared to a control group
however there's also a pretty large
fraction of people who fail
uh in reaching their goals and then
often they have to pay some penalty
for doing that now that's really bad
marketing for your product right if you
think about like selling this product if
you sort of like have half of your
customers are really unhappy about it
that's going to be very tricky to do so
there's lots of questions about how to
best design commitment devices
how can we perhaps target customers who
might not fail and
perhaps design them differently for
different people but we haven't
necessarily figured out how to do that
uh liangbai and gautam rao have a
similar and co-authors have a similar
example in of a health commitment
product in india
where essentially they try to
incentivize people to uh go to
hypertension
uh doctor visits to get like checkups
for their hypertension
lots of people say they would like to go
and so on and so forth you offer them
commitment devices to essentially
provide themselves incentives to go
pretty few
people actually sign up in the first
place which is also consistent with some
form of naivete and so on and so forth
but even among the people who sign up
lots of people actually fail
so you end up having people who
essentially set themselves incentives to
go to the doctor they're willing to pay
for
going in the future or setting
themselves incentives to go to the
doctor in the future
and then they have these incentives and
then the incentives are actually not
successful and they end up not going
again that's sort of very much
consistent with partial surface partial
uh with with naivete or at least partial
naivety or partial sophistication
um uh and sort of there's many questions
now about like if that's the case
how do we um design better commitment
devices that work for more people
that are more successful for people and
how do we avoid that some people sort of
sign up for them when they in fact are
doing worse
because again like that's really bad
marketing for your product and of course
it's bad for the people um uh who are
doing worse they would be essentially
better off if they had never been
uh offered this a device at least um
exposed
now are any questions on this
okay so then very briefly there's a
second view that you might have is to
say well maybe
commitment devices are just not that
helpful in some sense we have not
figured out how to do this companies
have had lots of time to figure this out
researchers have not figured this out in
a sense of like well we have lots of
evidence of demand for commitment in
terms of like people wanting commitment
devices
we have actually not that much evidence
of commitment devices being like
useful in the real world in the sense of
like persistently
uh showing that um they make things
better there are some examples to be
clear for example the data example data
entry example does show that like people
are more productive at work
and probably employers should do that
but another view would be like well if
commitment devices are not really
helping
so think of commitment devices as a way
of providing people some choice options
for given self-control problems or given
ivt
now there's different things you could
do you could do some things like in
terms of like trying to address people's
ivt and the problems that
ask you a little bit to think about that
how do you actually get people to be
uh less naive if that's sort of the
process demand for commitment
another way to say is you could try to
essentially try to reduce people's
present bias or get at the sources of
people's present bias overall
there's different ways and we have only
started so thinking about it or
coming up with some potential
explanations but for example one thing
uh a paper that we have
on on sleep finds that when people are
napping in the afternoon which you know
some of you do also in my class
um that um reduces your present bias and
and will afford tasks and also uh
savings so that's to say perhaps sleep
perhaps alcohol consumption perhaps
other sort of factors
might affect people's present bias so if
we could sort of understand these
underlying factors and if you could sort
of tackle them
that would be another way of getting
around potentially self-control problems
causing trouble
by sort of getting uh at the root of
this particular issue if you think
that's
an issue overall there's some other
research that i find quite interesting
which is
uh sort of the idea that you can present
bias is very much like
related to attention in the sense that
people pay too much attention to the
present
compared to the future so now if you
could sort of make the future more
salient in certain ways if you could
make people think more about the future
how things will be like
they might sort of behave more patiently
so hal hirschfield has like a series of
papers
um and this hershey is the guy on the
left
the picture that you see who
used sort of like computer software to
make people look older
so on the right of the screen you see
how horseshoed like uh i don't know 40
years older or something
and so what they did is they try to show
people essentially pictures of their
older selves
and this is how you're going to look
like in 40 50 years from now
and you know then think about how things
might be like in terms of like
um your health and so on and so forth
and then get people to make savings
choices and there's some evidence at
least that's sort of increasing people's
focus and attention to the future
might actually make them uh more patient
and there's quite a bit of work people
of people
trying to do that um right now so um
just to give you a brief summary i think
that
i said already almost everything that's
to be said exponential discounting is
like a
workhorse model of modern economics it's
extremely important
and just to be clear it's helpful for
many applications and it's been a very
successful models
there's some limitations and some things
that we cannot explain so
quasi-hyperbolic discounting or some
forms of this
different discounting models might be
able to improve uh the predictability
of our models commitment devices in
particular may help
with improve outcomes but we haven't
quite figured out how to make them
actually most useful for the world
there's lots of work research going on
in this area
next week we're going to talk about risk
preferences in particular i'd like you
to read
the paper by raymond and thaler 2001. in
recitation this week there will be more
in time preferences in particular
related to uh
the next problem set um and then sort of
an introduction to risk preferences
if you uh don't remember what this
preferences are you should very much
come to recitation and get a refresher
of that
thank you very much